[Music]
our war is not for our faith
we fight on foreign power from our soil
we are Allah Allah the Arthur killers
we fight without sorrow
[Music]
we wage war
[Music]
the only way
[Applause]
let go 3-1 - Charlie - actual go for
actual LZ is it safe time colonel about
two three one hit man teams are locked
and loaded for assault you are green to
go
colonel we may have a problem too lately
as well we're live
not until I say so
watch it a 3:1 how copy cheaply as well
traffic general barkhov was sent a new
shipment of chlorine gas to his Depot
but his mercs are prepping to move the
cams understand via convoy tonight
you're still clear to engage but live
fire on Russian military is prohibited
you cannot have an international
incident
guarantees Russian army won't respond on
this cake
understood Alan just locate the gas
comedy about cops trying to get off the
advertiser copy watch your head
all hitman teams push to yourself
echo 3 1 - watcher terrorist attack
multiple Marines ki-yay gasps stolen
we need evac now Roger tracking multiple
Russian forces headed your way sit tight
we're pushing to you for festival much
route separation is now compare mint
alized what the hell does that mean it
means you no longer have clearance
colonel
those are my Marines you need a QRF in
there right now it's not advisable and
that is not your colonel last well
general my man Norris give us a minute
miss ma'am we've got a situation the
Kremlin has suspended all deconfliction
channels the 6th fleet is pushing into
the Black Sea and chemical weapons are
now in the wild your fingerprints are
all over this Laswell fix it general
right now intelligence is our best
weapon we've tried intelligence get me a
better weapon
John as well where are you
Oh keep on I've got a problem Russians
we're Turtles fast chemical weapons find
its terrorist hands they could be
anywhere Paris New York
what can you breathe
we just did
they're a threat level is now critical
impossible multiple attack bombers or
something well we have snipers in
position
negative sergeant Anton Julie along the
public terrorist alert ooh sir Garrick
you don't turn something into a war zone
yeah yeah crystal up
looks like we're on our own lads we land
on it let's get it done
yeah a phone sergeant
it's a white van
weapons in view a stem saber - rayvin
white van multiple military age males
weapons visible moving to inset wife and
son
[Applause]
can you try it let me see if I go
most Isis form is clear but medical or
coming up everybody stay calm we're
gonna get you outta here
you broke it okay
[Applause]
[Music]
you're so close to those such
I shouldn't have happened in the first
place they said it's in how fast
so everyone can just keep pretending
with all war
you're a lot of [ __ ] century those
why if we got our hands tied let's just
take the bloody gloves off and fight
sir
cool
we don't stand a chance in hell with
these rules of engagement captain they
can tell us where they can tell us when
don't tell us out
remember track in that cell for weeks
you were the actual into homeless
quite this up
[Music]
like a
[Music]
Alcatel is claiming responsibility alex
is on the ground there looking for the
stolen Kemp's you only made the
liberation force on his side so I've
been concert mercy on you know commander
Kareem we're going to use my name photo
kill him
what is your message from Captain Price
medic arena call me Alex I'm listening
Alex this is classified
hello Adam jaws welcome
48 hours ago tariffs still a shipment of
Russian gas only I'll khatallah we'll do
this
Russia's make no distinction between out
they tell your people and I make no
distinction between alcohol and the
Russian army
they're both terrorists we would never
use these poisons in Elvis jacket before
they what take it to Europe what America
we live like this every day
commander it's time to go Croesus
Alex this is my brother uh no penance
are there PR CIA he works with Captain
Price then you killed Russians yes I
have friends you can help us but your
sister DeSales was next
of course my sister is in command and
the Russian army is still here this
occupation must end that we can all
agree on
yes general Barker's men control the
city we have plans to change that we
have no missiles but we have always if
you stay we can help you but if you stay
to fight
but I badly as ecstatic
[Music]
these tunnels are our lifeline we have
Intel Russian troop commanders are in
town today going to ambush them how
explosives I'll get their attention and
pull security away from the Russian base
leaving it open to attack we must hold
nothing back too far on that path and we
lose ourselves get set for the air base
attack be safe
Alex take those charges c4 with remote
detonator Thanks
watch my sister Zella make a food beer
Alex
[Music]
how do I look
[Music]
you lost good people today it is the
cost of this war now let's take
particles air base so that it deaths are
nothing vain we're in for a hell of a
fight so what are they idea has a plan
you're in my house I set up on the edge
of my space
[ __ ] dachshund check friends close
enemies closer
I told you we have our ways no grenades
so we improvise not burn if we fight
this war with sticks and stones city we
set up an army yesterday the Russians
only understand violence so I showed
them violence Barkov has an essence so
we have one two
RC planes obese people today if any part
monkey are we ready
yes commander let's fly let's fly to
that
I mean
they go ahead
[Applause]
[Music]
flying breaths let's get down
and base perimeter is dead ahead second
team will cover us with the cannon
enemy armor is destroyed now get after
the guys on foot
over toffee flavor one cruciate to high
heat don't be a stranger
so you do kill Russians all of the bad
ones
today was a great victory for us thank
you
we make a good team yes
we've both time but Barker will
retaliate
so will we Alexson commander Koreans
forces destroyed general bar coughs
forward operation space temporarily
limiting Russian air capability under 16
we need to move fast
sergeant Gary thanks to your in we track
the our guitarists are responsible for
the Piccadilly attack to a town house in
North London
three SAS things we'll get inside and
connected dots if the wolf is in
possession of the stolen Russian gas in
Isaac's turn we need to find them be
advised and they be non-combatants on
target set your shots
[Music]
togehter apples let's get yourself
just apply surgeon so we could buy
[Music]
[ __ ] now she was going for bloody
debt and they are good job we dropped it
in we made the right call sir about your
house we got location of the wolf the
attic of the Alcatel the townhouse was a
gold mine looks like we found the wolf
communication through the laptop of the
track to Roma's a hospital in Isaac's
dam where they are català leaders
believed to be holed up forest forces
will track terror activity at the
hospital while the Marine ground force
can be mobilized to advance on the
complex I go 3-1 will capture the wolf
for interrogation about the stolen
Russian gas
mocchi habanero superzero
my soldiers confirm that the hospital is
under siege and katanas taken civilians
as human shields they're protecting
someone or something tomorrow we find
out
[Music]
all fear sister Hadid is my best sniper
you can rely on him at all my fighters
when he's going to pound of flesh
I didn't to charge on this I told you II
would help you and you keeping your word
I don't know this to keep my ward
the invaders of my country have no
regard for human life
the gas kills all things even through
their gardens
[Music]
if you use these tactics you are my
enemy no exceptions
then al capella has given my people a
bad name
and we have paid dearly for their crimes
I want to see the wolf punished
I'll make sure you're at the Embassy for
the handoff the price
and you but will you go when this is
over
wherever they send me
you don't choose not exactly
[Music]
rest up tomorrow's a big day
[Music]
what about you and your man huh we'll be
here until sunrise
I'll cover the open corner
the hospital is at the end of the road
half a klick I'll be hoping it with the
Marines echo three one sergeant Griggs
all day
go me Alex no locals on this one not my
call
you Kareem all day
nice work it in the Russians we shed
friends and enemies it's folly wish you
[ __ ] honorees roll Alex
Daymond dog time to take this ship to
the
you'll find this a target-rich
environment watch the windows good guys
look like bad guys around here shit's
[ __ ] up
give me one 2x4 big five we got you
brother man
you're alright good wigs
Omar Silverman you are now in custody a
special operations force do exactly as
you're told
as your deadly hell yeah all demon teams
Marines are secure wolf is in the bag
let's move into the embassy
[Applause]
[Applause]
- six echo is on the third deck for our
V be advised primary entry point is
clear but that window is rapidly closing
three minutes three minutes my people
will be inside they will kill all of you
I chose to take you alive
I could still change my mind you have
the wrong man lies together much of them
we did not steal the gas you did someone
very dangerous whereas I wish I knew the
butcher is outside burn the city there
save yourself
daughter join us do not talk to her hey
tap the brakes I'm not your child old
man I lead soldiers you trained killers
but we are all killers here no I got a
bridge
[Music]
we're gonna move now
three one two two six shots fired
copy 3 1 / all those on the station
reposition a prep 3 back well jump 30
seconds
controllers down there
we have to recheck oh fast
okay okay take our three one primary
instruction file with down on the roof
there's a safe room into Facebook head
that will be right behind you
get in there girl
[Music]
booklet
he's gone they breached the wall
[ __ ] you know the garden captain we will
find him hadir get your team to the
crossroads bring everything you've got
yes sister Samantha the wolf is with the
butcher terrorist cells of a city hidin
Bravo wouldn't be a house to house in
soulish my people will help you if they
try to escape to the mountains but that
is only one day daddy I moved a highway
of death
the Russians bombed it during the
invasion killing the people trying to
escape there is a village at the
crossroads
I said hadeel and his fighters there to
prepare an ambush Alex and I will join
them and take up firing positions above
their own lying in wait for the
[Music]
Iowa is the lowest a beard has
reinforcements position to one which the
river we're easy prey for the Russians
out here
yes that window is short barkos men will
be on the hunt he's lost control
[Applause]
is it home let's move we have to cut the
roof up upon us before the ward is
village had families and laughter
laughter is the best medicine
tell me a joke what happens when this
CIA goes to sleep what they go
undercover well that probably better in
English you told it in English open the
tailgate quickly cover us
[Music]
[Music]
we had no choice back
all bets are off now
we said to me I stood the gas from the
Russians to help us only to help us
Goosen
got your back
we're together
suta I'll go ahead and make sure it's
safe keep behind me that's my god do as
I say and you will be safe
[Music]
so you are the little devils that killed
my soldiers
a Kistner
it was the thief
didn't know it's okay for good
[Music]
my brother always wanted to fight
without roles now he's broken although
how dear went north he was picked up by
a queue fighters in the foothills
voluntarily or by force
we don't know I'm sorry father your
brother is a Daedalus is an American
asset who was either with or in
terrorist hands idears fights not with
us he could have killed everyone when he
stole the gas but he chose not to how do
you know this I was there trying to stop
it why don't you tell me we believe it
was Al khattala we didn't know who's him
we know now
we're going after him tonight I'll come
with you you'll be hunting your own
brother he is not my brother
not anymore barkos gonna put a bounty on
his head
well let's get in first any further
complications are more at war with
Russia well let them come precursor it's
a bad idea
Farah what they care about all me well
usually what that means because here old
ferrati
an Oscar
fine
you have executed thority
all of you
imagery confirms Hadiya was in
possession of the remaining stolen gas
when he made direct contact with Alcatel
as most brutal enforcer the butcher
surveillance tracked their vehicles to a
residential complex in the Atlas
Mountains believed to be the wolf
stronghold Alexson fire will hold orbit
for secondary clearance while Bravo 6
leads the assault force to locate the
chemical agents retrieve hadir and
that's busted
hold of it Roger action
go Alex is yours hi Marie has a vest
there is no escape this is the end still
counting
we can use our metallics help me 20
seconds cut the wire exactly when I say
not before ready green wire
in three two one cut green next yellow
in two one
how did you logged on last one is red
there are two Reds top one into one now
cut this and good job thanks to you
good work how'd you learn that here's of
experience too many all stations this is
Echo three one in the blind jackpot
primary target is kie
it wasn't me
good kill twice thanks mate
[Music]
gratulations on the job well done
as much as we can all hear the ice in
the glass I'm afraid our toast has to
wait
hi dear and his new friends around the
move what are they one step at a time
no one said their friends the general
would tend to disagree Norris I asked
you to mental as well or I will
[Music]
command has officially be designated
virus forces you wanna translate that
from [ __ ] to English it means
they're on the list what list
foreign terror organization list
I've ordered my Marines to treat foras
army as hostels what
there are allies not anymore you keep
your Muppets on a short string kernel or
what [ __ ] unusual niche gate these
people need our support there's nothing
else we can do but there's plenty we can
do I'm tired of being told who my
friends are
Alex don't I'm going back to his extent
staying with fathers army what you're
doing is illegal
I'm pretty sure everything we do is
illegal only the good stuff you got
friends nearby you too
thank you
for everything
I was all over you
just like
I always have
wake up Adair is that you yes let me see
you
wake up fat how long have you been in
solitary ten days right
catch your breath
collect survivors and supplies we're
leaving
funny station time 10 minute
all right now the bar cops gonna come
and claim is dead yeah not desert of
that if you know he's gonna make you pay
for this we will make them pay
we'll be ready I'm gonna clear the road
to the north you can count they're safe
thank you the revolution begins analysis
that the water begins now brother it was
a hot rod
20 years of civil war there's nothing
simple about it
idears well-trained teamed up kidnap it
doesn't matter
he took the gas to Russia - he did that
without the toes home
got the network in the manpower could
you blame me
unofficially no but this is bigger than
hadir now
we've got two options have a taste of
her own medicine a lot of innocent
people in there die at the hands of a
Western SS cursing it's just a choice
what do you suggest business trip
unsanctioned
as your team
to smoke all right sergeant
I can get you in that today
host nation weapons on me David to me
as a hell of a view Nikolai was the
capital before Moscow the good advice I
got to a little more Alcatel inside good
spot parking here sucks
mr. butcher in the yellow shirt posture
for the embassy no gas and let her deal
easy shot hmm tempting how fast a
butcher gets us to a idea or the gas
attack goes off well if that happens
then we're all [ __ ]
let's gear up get able clock's ticking
this way
what's the time frame hours or less you
get to hear best I could do on short
notice
suppressors ammo no flash bangs
nice job need 40 Cal hollow points 150
grain got a favorite conceal it for now
but earlier the word dos Roach bring the
package on my way captain
oh no you want another struggle butcher
oh great deep enough for that sick
bastard sir
you'll have your chance right now Winnie
the butcher life
so look up we sweep the gossips and they
kind of let the others then move it on
the rear door rush comes off by signal
more before they see Mike we got
promised look who I trashed in the early
fight bet you think of everything they
can send your head home to your families
soccer
you can't hurt me you will piece of [ __ ]
but you captain
oh you can do better than that you think
I forgot your face sis are you sergeant
we need to break this boss the captain
we're about to Nikolai where's the
package
calling you now yep got a Nikolai you
get a package you come back here what
[Music]
I told you everything sergeant do what
you want with me I let my family oh you
have what you want
if you're going to shoot me theater
securing quarterly another drill will do
cruiser is yours it'll get you out of
the city
there's it Marcos estate he's gonna kill
him and start to world war mother forget
it first
correct get in the car cover us
[Music]
roach
[Music]
[ __ ] untie me contact us yet the is
Rudy McCarthy Nnamani FCM a loss to keep
his apostasy Emma carted Sally miss
Nick's this the shortest in the city of
Fuji
[Music]
by checkpoint
for us what is there a difference
roads bloat what's the plan
shock and awe
breakage
in seconds
holy [ __ ] Nikolai sector bacon whilst
they follow if they want
boss
looking another mess with women and
children I will over they were hostages
tray the gloves off you get blood on
your hands Kyle I said it works
where do we draw the line us huh
you draw the line wherever you need it
soldier
and to the day someone has to fight the
enemy scared of the dark
we get dirty and a world stays clean
that's the mission
now if you were having second thoughts
and I can do this a Milan
mosa
but second thoughts good
now let's get idea before he comes back
off
Alcatel a search party
have you brought a queue they're still
looking
we're not too late then let's get idea
before he starts a third world war
embark of spaceman
clear some ugly self you helped me
attack the lab yes
not on your life you going down for this
tap dish was a one-way trip for there
you knew that but you'll do the right
thing
yes boss tell me we're gonna finish this
we need support so we get it
captain please keep out of the plans
tell her the truth we'll have a chance
to tell the whole world I don't care
about the world
my sister
/ well what's she doing it
laughing so keep it on you this
the off switch returning to mophir
Russia
Brenda for
it's one way what's all of us
standby don't make this ugly captain
bear region it's a proxy war John we're
all just pawns in this you speak for
yourself
and iboga sir
[Music]
but there's yours in telephone
whatever you've got going on you
according finito
go he stays captain
Farah let's go
I know how this works captain not this
time
they gave the deer to the Russians okay
him if he's lucky looks like you saved
the free world again captain price ID
relocated bark off slab in eastern
Georgia gas Factory he had plans to
destroy you [ __ ] crazy
have a war a little crazy on me he's not
right Alex affirmative sir would you
help we can finish what he started
you're a good friend captain and the
worst enemy I'm sure but I do not cross
borders and invade I defend my people
here at home well sometimes the best
line of defense
solo
plans personnel
I see
a militia with no ties to the West could
carry out this mission
I don't blame the terrorists goodnight
I knew I could trust you
[Music]
if bar comes there he's mine operation
to destroy bar coughs gasps Nikolai's on
the inside he'll provide the explosives
two teams would influence my Garrick and
I will plant charges on the pipeline
fahren Alex you'll get a detonator from
Nikolai Richter main furnace when the
charges are set give a safe distance and
bring it down there support from those
world claims the way rest is up to us
troops in the open side of the bridge
[Music]
that's right shoes off
move it in
clear what's happened detonators [ __ ]
instead I'll go in there do what
regulate the furnace
you'll never get away in time I know
what I'm doing
Farah listen to me no you listen for me
because of this poison my people have
known something worse than war I've not
come this far to turn back I'm not
asking you to turn back
I'm asking you to give me the order how
will do that commander please I am NOT
your CEO
then who is because someone needs to
light this fire someone needs to kill
bark off that you can't do both
I've had an assignment on my whole life
this is what I believe in
give me the order
[Music]
you are a freedom fighter Alex
you're a born leader Farah say the word
go
yes ma'am
[Music]
what is not
[Music]
so here
I told you Father
[Music]
[Music]
captain vocals is dead sir Alex I'm not
getting out of here let's do this thank
you
yes ma'am
Oh clear captain
[Music]
my dresser would approve
what do
Kazakhstan
Oh
[Music]
t yeah well I'm a long way from a proper
pint rush it disowned Barkov well I
didn't have much choice did they he's
dead
you took a big bite out of that problem
John for now we're left unchecked it
won't be
general Shepherd pulled the files you
asked for what exactly is this about a
tell us fools we already have listen I
know I will tie them I can fund assets
not a loss
enjoy the tea then Sakai Avant's bar
cops thrown
I almost bury them in Pripyat the
vanillin that was the father this is the
son Victor lovely family you're big fans
of hot ears we'll explain why still
alive
they're gonna get him out they keep me
what I need
[Music]
who's your crown
Oh sergeant go okay they're calling gas
she never said anything
John what Tabish SAS sniper demolitions
goes by so why it's classified
very is Simon Reilly
there's no picture never not reversed
that's need-to-know - we got a deal
what do you call in this task force
on a full one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all of them
city's under evacuation Alka Tallis got
complete control
this place was nice once mr. Nimmo East
and West rebuilt her dance after the
goon if you didn't like that cooperation
now they've got armor heavy weapons
dentists with tanks was it a helmet
nice hit what's his name we don't know
but he's got friends in high places
she's rushing into
my counterpart in Moscow the CIA working
with the FSB that's the first time
camera of Captain Price Nikolai been a
bad boy from you that's a compliment
please we're all friends here
I owed you for Beirut
sergeant camera is going to help conduct
this operation these new weapons give
Alcatel is a power to turn acts of
terror into acts of war it's the problem
for everyone
we're launching a multilateral force to
hunt a Q's new leader and contain this
threat while we still can
okay worried start of your teams
you